notre école est en crise les évaluations
internationales montrent que nos élèves
réussissent moins bien que la petite
camarade des pays européens qui nous
entourent face à ce constat jusqu'à
présent qu'est-ce qu'on dit toujours
plus de moyens toujours plus d'argent
pourtant de la France consacre 5,2 % de
son PIB à l'effort d'éducation c'est
plus que beaucoup de pays d'Europe donc
c'est pas de toujours plus d'argent dont
tu as besoin dans notre école c'est de
réforme il faut arrêter d'injecter des
forces supplémentaires ça en repenser le
système et la proposition de loi que je
propose et qui est soutenu par mes
collègues les républicains elle vise à
quelques ruptures fondamentales faut
repenser notre système d'abord il faut
refaire confiance aux professeur il faut
redonner de la liberté aux
établissements aujourd'hui tout se
décide depuis le haut et souvent la
bureaucratie de l'éducation nationale
anniele toutes les initiatives sur le
terrain donc repartons de la base de
ceux qui sont au plus près du terrain au
plus près les enfants au plus près des
parents c'est à dire des professeurs les
chefs d'intervissement donnant de la
liberté de l'autonomie aux
établissements le deuxième axe ce sont
les savoirs fondamentaux il faut que
l'école apprenne à nouveau à lire à
écrire à compter elle se
dispersent-elles s'éparpille elle ne
fait pas bien son cœur de métier et pour
cela il vaut mieux former des
professeurs à l'apprentissage des
savoir-faireaux apprendre à lire et
écrire à compter à un enfant c'est un
métier particulier voilà pourquoi je
propose pour mon texte de séparer la
formation des professeurs du premier
degré métier particulier le vieux métier
d'instituteurs de la formation des
professeurs du second degré le troisième
axe de ma propulsion de loi c'est
d'avoir une approche différenciée aussi
pour l'école rurale l'éducation
nationale sait faire différemment par
exemple dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville dans les quartiers
de l'éducation prioritaire il faut
aujourd'hui faire différemment dans les
territoires de grande ruralité où
l'enclavement l'éloignement parfois la
créé aujourd'hui de vrais besoins
éducatifs particuliers l'école n'y
répond pas un nouveau pacte entre
l'école de République les maires et la
ruralité c'est un signe fort que nous
voulons envoyer au maire des tireurs qui
aiment leur école et qui se battent pour
leur école et puis le troisième axe
c'est la laïcité et les menacer et les
menacer au quotidien dans les
enseignements et dans la vie le scolaire
il faut réaffirmer que l'école est
laïque que la laïcité à l'école a une
dimension particulière parce qu'il y a
une vieille histoire de la construction
de notre République laïque et de l'école
et bien nous nous républicains nous la
réaffirmons avec force parce que nous
croyons que une école laïque c'est le
lieu du vivre ensemble c'est le lieu de
la cohésion de la nation et que nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui de travailler
pour vivre ensemble et à la coalition de
la nation nous revenons un peu
fondamentaux de l'école c'est de
l'autorité du respect des savoir-faire
de la laïcité en faisant confiance aux
professeur en leur donnant de la liberté
sur le terrain
[Musique]